you think it's fair for women to require
a certain income for them to submit
it's not really about fairness it's just
that some
way it is it is an exchange of security
and commodity for love and and child um
i mean it is kind of i don't want to
make it out to be like i mean i know
disney wants to make you believe that
you know love and all that starry-eyed
stuff can happen but in reality most
people are looking at you know what am i
giving up going into this and what am i
getting in return right that's why i
brought up the dowry earlier is because
there is some history that that does
correlate a bit with you have to have
something in order to get get a girl
so
so what do you think i would say it's
okay for her to have that standard so
long as she understands
that the man is going to have standards
for her
so the more you ask from a man the more
the higher standards he's gonna have for
you
so one thing that we obviously see all
the time is
the more a woman
requires a man to make
a lot of the time the more attractive
she has to be and maintain for him so if
you think that correlation if you think
okay well okay well the guy who i would
accept and submit to
right has to be making 100k
which is in the top
10
of earners
you better make sure you're in the top
10 of most attractive women consistently
facts
i mean sorry oh me oh yeah um
i would say
i don't think it's fair that we put a
monetary amount on things in terms of
submission i think a woman should submit
to the man regardless of how much she
earned
in that sense but at the same time we
have to just like come banks he said we
have to base
it on reality and what reality your life
is you have to make money to be able to
submit if you want your missus to stay
at home and do nothing there has to be
enough money coming in for her to be
able to do that and for you to be able
to live that life of coming home when
your slippers are ready your dinner's
all warm and everything's all all nice
and cozy for you you have to make enough
money for that to happen that's just the
reality but i was gonna say i was gonna
say on that i think um
[Music]
if a woman is going to be the kind of
woman that she submits in a relationship
you submit to the man you choose
so there's no kind of okay this is who i
choose but he actually doesn't make
enough so i'm not gonna submit it's not
that if he doesn't make enough for you
if that's the standard of yours then
that's not the man you choose
but if you choose him
right then you are inadvertently saying
i submit myself to you if that's the
kind of woman you're going to be it's
the same way like we don't say to guys
ah well how attractive does a girl have
to be for you to protect her
you know i mean don't go okay well
no one does that like if a man chooses a
woman that's the woman he's chosen to
serve in the way that a man knows how to
serve well it's kind of funny because i
always hear girls say broke men
shouldn't have an opinion but we don't
guys don't say fat chicks shouldn't have
an opinion
speak your truth i think speak your
truth everyone can have an opinion but
that doesn't mean people listen to you
it's as simple as that yeah that doesn't
mean how valued your opinion is yeah
exactly right that's it that's it what
ish do you want you think it's fair
uh do i think we'll sorry yeah we use
the camera we got you come on come on
i just say for the audience issues when
they're spanking your pair trainers
right now
[Laughter]
what are you what do you think um what
do i think about do you think it's fair
that that men have to have a certain
amount of money
i don't really think about fairness i
think the world works the way it works
if you earn enough money
there are certain things that you have
access to or
or are privileged to and so um
you find that the more you earn
the better you get
the more attractive women you're able to
attain and so
it's just the rules of nature
the game is a game that's how i just
learn to play it okay so question for
the women what percent of men do you
think make 70 000 pounds a year or more
in the uk
20
15
maybe
what do you think
um fifteen percent
okay
eighteen percent
so according this
i think i'm reading it right it says 60
000 pounds is in the 90th percentile
no it's not i don't i don't know if i'm
reading this right but i think this is
what it said the thing is uh it all
depends if you're looking at london if
you're looking at you will be
from pasadena oh it could be oh that's
probably why let me let me break it down
by london yeah because london it has a
higher
much higher fee
than anywhere else in the country
uh so yeah um let me just look it up
real quick london income breakdown
but even if we double it that's still
can ask a question for the ladies yeah
you know when you said about um
you know you said about okay this is how
much um
you know a man would have to make for
you to submit to him and obviously you
don't have to
share that this information but
what were were your answers relative to
how much you earn
yeah technically yeah
okay
so if you earn less the threshold might
be lower and if you're more the
threshold would probably be higher
see there's the trick the trick in this
in this situation what i find is that
even though you say um you you're happy
with a man who earns 50 60 000 pounds
and if that is relative to what you earn
what you're not taking into account is a
lot of men can or want to say that once
my you know once i get married i don't
want my woman to work at all so actually
it's not relative to what you earn
because he may not want you to work at
all so what you earn is zero no no but i
was asking a question of
for them yeah what their preference was
as to who they would submit to was it in
relationships it was in relation to how
much they are
okay it actually
so if you uh if you earned half a
million a year you would still say 70k
oh well no no no
because if you can make a hundred
thousand pounds a year then why would
you you wouldn't you wouldn't submit to
a man that makes 50. well no i wouldn't
but i thought you meant as in was i
considering the amount that i earned
comparing it to the amount that i would
submit to
no that's what i've waited no no
yes yes because i wasn't comparing the
amount that i earned to the amount that
i
would submit to bob because because i
guess let's let's even ish is gonna look
up like what the actual percentages of
men that make over a certain amount but
so do you think
do you think you're in the top 20
percent of females
to get that
top 20 innocent what financially no just
like in what men value which is like
femininity beauty it starts with looks
femininity beauty do you think you're in
the top 20 of females no
so then if if
i then you probably would be dating a
gut be dating a guy that makes less
do you think it'd be a problem if you
couldn't submit to a guy that dates less
do you think that would cause issues in
a relationship
it would yeah i'm just talking from
experience from what i've observed from
other people's marriages yeah yeah what
do you think
yeah i think it most likely would yeah
it would
so